On the evening of August 5, 2012 Pacific Daylight
Time, NASA's Mars Rover, named Curiosity,
entered Mars' atmosphere at 20,000km/h. Drag
slowed it down to around 1600km/hr, at which
point a parachute opened. This parachute slowed
the Rover more, to about 320km/hr, or 90 m/s.
Finally, after rockets decelerated it completely,
the rover was lowered to the surface of Mars.
Every step of this dance was carefully choreographed
and rehearsed in many experiments here on
Earth. But how could NASA engineers be sure
that their designs would work on a totally
different planet? The answer is a problem-solving
method called dimensional analysis.
This video is part of the Problem Solving
video series.
Problem-solving skills, in combination with
an understanding of the natural and human-made
world, are critical to the design and optimization
of systems and processes.
Hi, my name is Ken Kamrin, and I am a professor
of mechanical engineering at MIT. Dimensional
analysis is a powerful tool; I use it, NASA
uses it, and you will too.
Before watching this video, you should be
familiar with unit analysis, and understand
the difference between dependent and independent
variables.
By the end of this video, you will be able
to use dimensional analysis to estimate the
size of a parachute canopy that can slow the
Rover down to 90 m/s on its descent to Mars.
Before we talk about dimensional analysis,
we need to know what dimension is. Dimensions
and units are related, but different, concepts.
Physical quantities are measured in units.
The dimension of the physical quantity is
independent of the particular units choosen.
For example:
Both grams and kilograms are units, but they
are units of mass.And mass is what we'll call
the dimension.
There are 5 fundamental dimensions that we
commonly deal with: length, mass, time, temperature,
and charge.
All other dimensions are obtained by taking
products and powers of these fundamental dimensions.
In this video, we'll be dealing
with length, which we denote by the letter
L, mass, which we denote M, and time, T. For
example, no matter how you measure the physical
quantity velocity, it has the dimension, which
we denote with square brackets, of length
divided by time, or length times time to the
negative 1 power.
Pause the video here and determine the dimension
of energy.
Energy has dimension Mass times
Length squared over Time squared.
Okay, great, so what's the big deal? How is
this useful?
Remember NASA's rover? Part of the landing
sequence calls for a parachute to slow the
vehicle down. Suppose it is our job to design
the parachute to slow the Rover to exactly
90m/s. The terminal velocity of the Rover
depends on the mass of the rover itself and
its heat shield, and several different variables
related to the parachute design: the material
of the canopy, the diameter of the hemispherical
parachute canopy, the number of suspension
lines, etc.
For simplicity, let's suppose that all parachute
parameters other than the diameter of the
canopy have already been determined. Our goal
is to find the canopy diameter that is as
small as possible, but will correspond to
the desired terminal velocity of 90 m/s.
Clearly, we can't test our designs on Mars.
The question is: how can we get meaningful
data here on Earth that will allow us to appropriately
size the parachute for use on Mars? How do
we predict the behavior of a parachute on
Mars based on an Earth experiment? And what
variables do we need to consider in designing
our experiment on Earth? This is where a problem
solving method called dimensional analysis
can help us.
Before we get started, we must first determine
what the dependent and independent variables
are in our system.
The dependent variable is terminal velocity.
This is the quantity that we wish to constrain
by our parachute design. So what variables
affect the terminal velocity of the parachute
and rover system?
The diameter of the parachute canopy is one
such independent variable. Take a moment to
pause the video and identify others.
Ok. Here's our list: canopy diameter, mass
of the Rover (we assume the mass of the parachute
to be negligible), acceleration due to gravity,
and the density and viscosity of the atmosphere.
For this problem, we can assume that the dependence
of the terminal velocity on atmospheric viscosity
is negligible, because the atmosphere on Mars
like the atmosphere on Earth is not very viscous.
If we wanted to derive a functional relationship
that would work, for example, underwater,
it would be important that we include viscosity
as an independent variable.
Why didn't we include the surface area of
the parachute canopy in our list of independent
variables?
Pause the video and take a moment to discuss
with a classmate.
We didn't include the surface area of the
canopy, because it is not independent from
the diameter of the canopy.
In fact, we can determine the area as a function
of diameter. So we don't need both!
Question: Could we use the surface area instead
of the diameter? Absolutely. We need the variables
to be independent, but it doesn't matter which
variables we use! The key is to have identified
all of the correct variables to begin with.
This is where human error can come into play.
If our list of variables isn't exhaustive,
the relationship we develop through dimensional
analysis may not be correct!
Once we have the full list of independent
variables, we can express the terminal velocity
as some function of these independent variables.
In order to find the function that describes
the relationship, we need do several experiments
involving 4 independent variables, and fit
the data. Phew, that's a lot of work! Especially
because we don't know what the function might
look like.
But whenever you have an equation, all terms
in the equation must have the same dimension.
Multiplying two terms multiplies the dimensions.
This restricts the possible form that a function
describing the terminal velocity in terms
of our 4 other variables can take, because
the function must combine the variables in
some way that has the same dimension as velocity.
And many functions—exponential, logarithmic,
trigonometric --cannot have input variables
that have dimension. What would e to the 1kg
mean? What units could it possibly have?
We're going to show you a problem solving
method that will allow you to find the most
general form of such a function. This method
is called dimensional analysis.
We begin this process by creating dimensionless
versions of the variables in our system. We
create these dimensionless expressions out
of the variables in our system, so we don't
introduce any new physical parameters.
The first step is to take our list of variables,
and distill them down to their fundamental
dimensions.
Remember our fundamental dimensions are length,
mass, and time.
Distilling gravity to its fundamental dimension,
we get length per time squared. Now you distill
the remaining variables of velocity, diameter,
mass, and density into their fundamental dimensions.
Pause the video here.
Velocity is length per time; diameter is length;
mass is mass; and density is mass per length
cubed.
The second step is to express the fundamental
dimensions of mass, length, and time in terms
of our independent variables.
We can write M as little m.
We can write L as mass divided by density
to the 1/3 power.
We can write T as velocity divided by gravity.
We had many choices as to how to write these
fundamental dimensions in terms of our variables.
In the end, it doesn't matter which expressions
you choose.
The third step is to use these fundamental
dimensions to turn all of the variables involved
into dimensionless quantities. For example,
the terminal velocity v has dimension of length
over time. So we multiply v by the dimension
of time, and divide by the dimension of length
to get a dimension of one.
We define a new dimensionless variable vbar
as this dimensionless version of v.
Now you try; find dbar, mbar, gbar, and rhobar. Pause
the video here.
You should have found that dbar is d times rho over m to the 1/3.
Mbar is 1. Gbar is v squared over g times rho over
m to the 1/3., and rho bar is 1.
Now we can rewrite the equation for velocity
in terms of the new dimensionless variables.
It is a new function, because the variables
have been modified. Notice that vbar is equal
to gbar. This means that vbar and gbar are
not independent! So our function for vbar
cannot depend on gbar. Also, notice that mbar
and rho bar are both equal to one, so our
function doesn't depend on them either.
This has simplified our relationship: vbar
is a function of only one variable, dbar.
And remember that dbar is dimensionless, so
it is just a real number. This means that,
phi can be any function.
The forth and final step is to rearrange to
find a formula for the terminal velocity.
The key here is that this equation for the
terminal velocity has the correct units.
And this formula is so general, that any expression
with dimension of Length over Time can be
written in terms of this formula by defining
phi in different ways. Let's see how. First,
create an expression from the independent
variables that has the same dimension as velocity.
One such expression is the square root of
g times d. By setting the formula for v equal
to the square root of gd, we see that by setting
phi equal to the identity function phi(x)
= x, the two sides of the equation can be
made equal.
And in fact, we claim that any expression
with the correct dimension of Length over
time created using these variables can be
written in terms of this formula by simply
changing the definition of phi!
It can be fun to try this. Come up with different
formulas that have the correct dimension.
You can even add them together. Then see if
you can find a way to define phi so that our
formula is equal to the expression you wrote.
Pause the video here.
Now you may be concerned because this formula
is not unique. We made some choices about
how to represent our fundamental dimensions.
What happens if we make different choices?
Here we chose M, L, and T this way: M was
little m, L was d, and T was v over g. Running through
the dimensional analysis process with this
choice of fundamental dimensions, we obtain
an equation for v that looks like this.
To see that these two formulas are equivalent,
we set the arguments under the square root
equal, and find that we can express phi as
a function of psi.
So any formula with the
correct dimension can be expressed by this
general formula.
And this general formula works for any rover
on any planet whose terminal velocity through
the atmosphere depends on the same variables.
Because it is a general law!
Of course, we still don't know what this function
phi is! In order to find phi, we can fit experimental
data from any planet, for example, Earth.
On Earth, we know the gravity and atmospheric
density. We can specify the mass of a test
rover to be 10kg.
Then we might set up Earth bound experiments
by varying the canopy diameter of a parachute
between 1m to 20m and measuring the terminal
velocity. For example, suppose we obtained
the following data on Earth.
Then we could convert this data to the dbar,
vbar axes, by scaling the variables v and
d according to the Earth values for the mass,
gravity, and atmospheric density. We can fit
this data to some best-fit curve. And this
best fit curve is our best approximation to
the function phi.
Now that we have phi, we can transform the
axes again to represent the canopy diameter
and terminal velocity on Mars. This is done
by converting vbar and dbar to v and d by
scaling according to known values of the gravity,
atmospheric density, and mass of the rover
on Mars!
To find the diameter, we find the point on
the v-axis that corresponds to a terminal
velocity of 90m/s, and use our curve to determine
the diameter that corresponds to this terminal
velocity! Now we have the specification we
need to design the size of our parachute to
be used on the descent to Mars!
In this example, we used dimensional analysis
to restrict the possible form of a function
describing the terminal velocity of the Mars
rover as a function of parachute canopy diameter,
gravitational acceleration, atmospheric density,
and the mass of the rover.
This allowed us to design a parachute for
use on Mars based on Earth bound experiments.
In general, the process of dimensional analysis
involves... 1.
Identifying the dependent variable and independent
variables,
2. Expressing the relevant fundamental dimensions
in terms of the variables found in step (1),
3. Generating dimensionless expressions for all
of the variables using expressions from step
(2).
4. Producing a functional relationship between
the dimensionless dependent variable in terms
of the remaining independent dimensionless
expressions.
5. Rearranging to determine a formula for the
variable of interest. And
6. Performing experiments to determine the form
of the general real valued function that appears
in the formula.
We've just shown you a powerful tool which can
save you a lot of time. So the next time you
encounter a difficult challenge, you might just
want to try... Dimensional Analysis.